that all-important six-man 20 000
screaming fans
in their own arena doncic with 14-7
george gets by and he's fouled and now
you know what i really hope that
we get through this game clean
[Applause]
because that foul right there
yeah that's that's that's the flagrant
that's he scratched he grabbed him right
across the face great job right there
that's just that's just not needed
that's just that's just not needed well
they will go
to the monitor to see if this will be
upgraded to a flagrant foul on the swipe
by tim hardaway jr
and look how far back he comes
ow look at how far back he swipes that
arm and goes back and
yeah he's trying to get the block but
that followed through
just to present the other side of it
here that does look back at the
bad at the end but he did make contact
with the ball
first so you're gonna take up for that
when we watch these other games and it's
a breakaway
foul and it's beau bond and somebody
barely touches him and it's a flagrant
tin and that's not
what i like to do here is present both
sides of the story okay
i felt like you were going on the
flagrant side pretty fast and i never
going to play recital so that should
show you
that what i'm saying is pretty true all
right all right
wow he said he got the ball first now
now you've intimidated me i second no
well we'll see what they come up with
here
yeah and they're gonna they're gonna
call that a flager one
okay so kane fitzgerald is in agreement
with you chris webber i knew you were
going to win that one i just could be
right
broken clock is right twice and i give
one time to thee
no but i definitely hear what you're
saying because the swiping you don't
necessarily look he did get the ball
first but that followed through that
attention and
the fact that he didn't go over there
and grab pg and say my bad you know
you can kind of judge intent by after
the action
how that player kind of walks away
so the full wind-up and it's a flagrant
one so
george will shoot the t
shots and possession for the clippers as
they try to add to their lead it is a
monster lead they've had two big runs
in this game in the first half 19-0 and
11-0
paul george in his playoff career
averaging 20 plus points per game
he's been a 36 percent three-point
shooter in his playoff career
76 playoff games leading up to this
season